avec mon plateau Bertrand Houillon
bonsoir bonsoir mère de la commune de
Magny-les-Hameaux également l'un des
vice-président de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors vous
avez présenté vous vos vœux au manicois
et Mani quoi le 8 janvier on l'imagine
une thématique qui revient beaucoup dans
toutes les têtes en ce début d'année
c'est celle de la sobriété énergétique
ensuite notamment à la forte inflation
comment la commune fait-elle face à
cette thématique et ce qui a des choses
qui sont prévues aussi sur l'année 2023
en matière de sobriété énergétique alors
on a déjà engagé un certain nombre
d'actions depuis octobre novembre
dernier notamment sur les réductions des
chauffages sur une attention
particulière sur l'éclairage on était
déjà passé sur une bonne partie de la
commune sur l'ensemble de nos hameaux
sur de l'extinction de l'éclairage
public qu'on a qu'on a étendu à
l'ensemble à l'ensemble de la commune
et on continue cette année par rapport
aussi à du changement de nos éclairages
dans les bâtiments communaux avec les
LED même si on l'avait commencé on va
l'accélérer tout simplement cette année
et puis on continue nos travaux de
rénovation énergétique qui sont un
élément important puisque pour donner un
exemple on est sur quasiment 60%
d'économies en consommation de chauffage
sur une école qui a été sur un centre de
loisirs qui a été rénové énergétiquement
donc c'est vraiment des enjeux très
forts on n'a pas attendu cette
problématique d'inflation de l'énergie
pour pouvoir s'atteler assez assez
difficultés sur l'éclairage public par
exemple depuis 2019 on est déjà à 20%
d'économies le tout alors dans un
contexte vous l'avez dénoncé aussi dans
vos vœux de baisse de dotation de l'État
vous estimez qu'en 10 ans vous l'avez
dit l'État a pris 1,5 millions d'euros à
la commune c'est difficile aujourd'hui
d'agir avec de moins en moins de moyens
pour les maires il faut savoir grosso
modo une rénovation énergétique d'un
bâtiment public on en a au moins pour un
million cinq
donc voilà ce million cinq voilà où il
pourrait passer pour pouvoir accélérer
et répondre à l'enjeu de changement
climatique aujourd'hui il se trouve que
à côté de à côté de ces enjeux de
rénovation de bâti on a aussi des
services publics qu'on rend aux
habitants et c'est dotations ne sont pas
venues de nulle part c'est pas juste un
cadeau de l'État c'était des dotations
qui étaient faites pour
compenser les services publics délégués
par l'État aux communes l'état civil la
gestion des bâtis des écoles les routes
tout ça aujourd'hui on doit le faire
mais finalement avec plus d'argent de la
part de l'état où on était à peu près à
165 euros par habitant il y a 10 ans en
dotation de l'État aujourd'hui on est à
14,50 €. donc avec quand même une baisse
de dotation de l'État des projets quand
même qui sont en cours on va parler
justement de ces grands projets de
l'année 2023 les nouveautés les nouveaux
dossiers qui pourraient venir sur la
table pour manier lié à moi alors il y a
un projet en cours dont on parle depuis
plusieurs années c'est cette rénovation
reconstruction du collège Albert
Einstein est-ce qu'il y aura du nouveau
cette année pour pour le collège Mani
quoi c'est comme vous le dites un gros
dossier depuis longtemps ça fait plus de
10 ans qu'on en parle
ça avait été reporté au fur et à mesure
aujourd'hui on a donc un dossier de
démolition reconstruction de collège
avec des matériaux bio sourcés avec une
rénovation du coup énergétique
importante pour pour tout ça avec des
espaces aussi en cours qui seront des
espaces très végétalisés
je remercie le département de s'engager
dans dans cette démarche parce qu'en
plus ça correspond exactement à ce qu'on
demandait au niveau de la commune étant
dans un parc naturel régional pour avoir
quelque chose d'exemplaire en termes de
bâti
on va avoir une réunion jeudi le jury
pour le choix du de l'entreprise qui va
travailler le sujet et ensuite on espère
un démarrage des travaux 2024 2025
sachant que ce sont des travaux lourds
impactant à la fois pour les riverains
mais aussi pour les élèves et l'ensemble
du du personnel éducatif puisque on sera
aussi en site occupé pendant ces travaux
donc on se coordonne avec l'ensemble des
départs des services du département pour
pouvoir mener au mieux ces travaux et ça
va être un grand bonheur une fois que ça
sera fait donc du concret en 2023 et
début des travaux espérés dès l'an
prochain peut-être pour ce collège
einsteinmo va aussi disposer d'une
nouvelle médiathèque alors jusqu'à
présent on va pouvoir voir les images
elle était installée au sein de bâtiment
préfabriqué quand sera-t-il dans les
prochains mois du coup comment ça va
évoluer sur ce dossier alors là aussi
c'est un ancien dossier des villes
historiques de de l'ex-ville nouvelle
c'était les derniers bâtiments
préfabriqués pour une médiathèque qui
est de la compétence de l'agglomération
les discussions abouties à une
programmation
sur laquelle également on est totalement
satisfait pour avoir un bâtiment qui
sera aussi au niveau énergétique très
exemplaire et qui permettra aux
habitants d'avoir un lieu public de
lecture qui soit totalement adaptée avec
un agrandissement par rapport à l'état
actuel aujourd'hui le permis de
construire
doit être déposé
et ensuite c'est les démarches
administratives on va dire on espère
pouvoir
bénéficier de cette médiathèque d'ici
fin 2024 début 2025 attention sur les
dates par rapport au travaux
actuellement ça peut être très parce que
en ce moment avec un certain nombre de
pénuries de matériaux de retard de
d'effectifs des entreprises de travaux
publics ça peut parfois prendre
énormément de retard on est à l'abri de
rien il y a un dossier aussi qui en
suspens et ce bâtiment de la Maison de
l'Environnement qui dont l'agglomération
de 50 ans en ville en Yvelines a mis fin
aux activités sur place aussi depuis
plusieurs années ce qui est un nouveau
projet qui émerge est-ce que il y a du
nouveau aussi sur sur ce dossier je
pourrais voir des nouveautés en 2023
alors sur ce dossier là on continue de
discuter avec l'agglomération rien n'est
encore rien n'est encore fait
voilà quelques événements on continue
discuter aujourd'hui il se passe en fait
quelques événements même depuis 2015
depuis l'abandon de cette de ce projet
de Maison de l'environnement par
l'agglomération puisque la commune
occupe les lieux et finalement permet
que ce lieu ce bâtiment puisse être
utilisé et reste utilisable alors
l'autre projet d'envergure bien sûr pour
la commune c'est cette ligne 18 du Grand
Paris Express le métro doit relier Orly
à Versailles à l'horizon 2030 le tracé
passe par la commune de Manille liamo il
y aura un arrêt à 50 ans en Yvelines au
niveau de la commune de Guyancourt et on
sait que vous avez été opposé au projet
en tout cas vous avez porté aussi un
projet alternatif puisqu'on sait que ce
tracé sur le plateau de Saclay se fera
en aérien est-ce que aujourd'hui vous
avez encore des moyens d'action est-ce
que le tracé est totalement défini
est-ce que il y a encore des moyens
d'action pour pour le bien que vous êtes
cette commune de Magny-les-Hameaux il y
a aussi d'autres mères qui étaient
opposé à ce projet ensemble avec les
autres mères et les habitants des autres
communes concernées et les agriculteurs
du plateau on continue d'intervenir au
maximum pour pouvoir permettre que si
l'État a choisi cette ligne et continue
de la choisir quelle passe sur nos
territoires sans abîmer les territoires
en tranchées ouvertes ou couverte au
maximum tout simplement pour des
questions de continuité agricole pour
des questions
d'environnement pour des questions de
bruit aussi
sachant que par exemple les les études
qui nous sont montrées aujourd'hui
démontre que les le niveau de bruit est
supérieur aux préconisations l'OMS
aujourd'hui dans 10 ou 20 ans l'État
français devra intégrer ses
préconisations dans la loi et derrière
qu'est-ce qu'on fait donc ça c'est pas
tranché on peut encore agir sur le sujet
non on fera tout pour permettre que si
l'État continue de choisir ce cette
ligne là dans les années futures puisque
c'est un programmation 2030 on
continuera de tout faire pour que ça ne
mette pas en péril le territoire où ça
passe 2027 pour la partie estonienne
2030 pour la partie yvelinoise on a vu
déjà des premiers coups de pioche au
niveau des communes de Palaiseau de
Saclay est-ce que à Magny-les-Hameaux il
y aura des premiers travaux cette année
c'est où ce sera plutôt dans les
prochaines a priori non il y a encore
une nouvelle enquête publique puisque
les emprises de chantier et a priori les
emprisent qui seront programmées dans le
futur avec avec ces climats changent au
fur et à mesure des mois donc rien ne
semble a priori stabiliser aujourd'hui
alors en 2022 à Manille un mot on a vu
s'implanter aussi une nouvelle structure
c'est graines d'avenir une école qui
permet à des jeunes sans condition
d'accéder à des formations diplômantes
pour le métier de maraîcher primeur
alors la nouveauté en 2023 en tout cas
on l'espère pour 2023 Thierry Marx qui
va normalement implanter sa cuisine
mode d'emploi c'est une cuisine
d'application finalement pour pour le
chef voilà la ferme de bulloyer c'est un
patrimoine incroyable à
Magny-les-Hameaux une ferme du 15e
siècle et qui aujourd'hui en train de se
transformer entière lui agricole en
entière lieu d'insertion sociale et en
lieu de vie aussi on a la ferme école
avec donc des jeunes qui apprennent et
qui apprennent ces métiers autour de la
production agricole et de la vente de
produits agricoles et sera adossé donc à
cette ferme école cette cuisine
d'insertion qui va permettre donc
l'apprentissage des métiers de cuisine
et de services et évidemment en
cuisinant des produits de la ferme
directement donc on continue de
progresser et c'est et c'est des
formations qui sont essentielles
aujourd'hui notamment pour notre
territoire pour
permettre à des jeunes d'accéder à des
métiers d'avenir qui sont la production
agricole dont on a énormément besoin et
qui sont les métiers de la restauration
dont on a aussi énormément besoin et un
dernier projet dont je voulais parler
avec vous c'est la maison Madeleine une
maison intergénérationnelle et solidaire
qui devrait voir le jour à la fin de
l'année c'est ça ou en tout cas les
travaux vont débuter cette année
l'objectif est un dépôt de permis sur
dans l'année on accompagne ce dossier
porté par une association qui est un
dossier vraiment innovant qui part sur
le principe que
toutes les personnes quel que soit les
conditions quel que soit le niveau
d'autonomie peuvent réussir à vivre
ensemble on a choisi on a acheté un
terrain directement dans le centre bourg
pour permettre à des personnes qui qui
sont plutôt très âgés qui sont en
situation de handicap des familles
monoparentales des jeunes étudiants de
pouvoir vivre ensemble avec chacun sa
partie privative avec des espaces
communs un café ouvert sur l'extérieur
et éventuellement une crèche aussi pour
pour accompagner tout ça voilà c'est
innovant donc qui dit innovation dit que
ça rentre pas forcément dans toutes les
cases l'habitat inclusive c'est ça
malheureusement aujourd'hui et
l'association essaye de boucler un
certain nombre de financement notamment
par rapport au fonctionnement avec le
département et j'espère qu'on va y
arriver et quels sont les autres grands
dossiers à suivre en 2023 à
Magny-les-Hameaux alors on a un sujet
qui s'appelle macour passe au vert qui
est la végétalisation de nos corps
d'école pour pouvoir déminéraliser au
maximum tous ces espaces là et lutter
contre les îlots de chaleur c'est c'est
un vaste sujet sur l'ensemble de nos
cours nous avons également un dossier
sur la rénovation énergétique qui est le
gymnase Auguste Delaune qui est en
démolition reconstruction sur le parti
qui est un dossier aussi complexe que
nous menons et on va entamer d'autres
sujets de rénovation énergétique sur une
autre école des cette année avec une
étude et puis on va lancer une étude sur
un réseau de chaleur avec notre et les
évolutions technologiques qu'il y a sur
ce datacenter et là encore ça va être un
vase dossier notre objectif et de
pouvoir
vérifier si on pourrait via ce data
center
utilisé l'énergie pour recouvrir
l'ensemble des équipements publics voilà
pour les grands dossiers à
Magny-les-Hameaux en 2023 et pour
terminer on passe à l'interview express
[Musique]
le principe Bertrand Houillon 5
questions des réponses courtes oui un
nom un pour ou contre parfois quelques
explications je vais vous demander de
les donner en 20 30 secondes grand
maximum et ce qu'en 2023 vous
augmenterez les impôts locaux à
Magny-les-Hameaux le débat d'orientation
budgétaire a lieu au début à la fin du
mois là donc on va étudier tout ça avec
l'ensemble des conseillers municipaux
pour l'instant c'est pas totalement
défini
évidemment avec ce qu'on a évoqué
d'évolution budgétaire comme dans
beaucoup de collectivités ça risque
d'être oui alors certaines communes ont
fait le choix de passer à une limitation
de vitesse à 30 km/h c'est le cas de
manier les hameaux de votre expérience
et ce qu'il faudrait l'étendre aux
autres communes est-ce que vous
conseillerez un maire d'une commune
voisine de passer aussi aux 30 km/h
alors on l'a défini depuis le 1er
décembre dernier donc on en est encore
au tout début l'ensemble des parties
agglomérées donc des parties en ville de
notre de notre commune sont en zone 30
c'est tout simplement une question de
priorité à partir du moment où on est en
ville où il y a de l'habitat la priorité
au piétons et aux cyclistes pour faire
très attention et c'est
les piétons et les cyclistes qui sont
les plus vulnérables sur l'espace public
donc moi je conseillerais à tout le
monde d'y aller pour permettre justement
que ça devienne une règle éventuellement
le bio dans les cantines vous en avez
fait aussi le choix un peu plus de 50%
même 60% de mieux dans les cantines
manioises est-ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre l'obligation du bio dans les
cantines dans les cantines illinoises et
françaises forcément tout le monde doit
y passer pour ma part après obligation
ou pas tout le monde doit y aller mais
au-delà de la question du bio il y a
aussi la question du local puisque ça
sert à rien de faire traverser la terre
entière pour du bio donc du local de
saison et des produits aussi qui
bénéficient d'un certain nombre de label
je pense à la viande par exemple
l'objectif est d'en avoir une
traçabilité vraiment précise de
l'ensemble malheureusement dans
l'actualité on a vu des maires des élus
victimes d'agression ou de menaces
est-ce que l'exercice de vos fonctions
vous avez déjà vous avez déjà senti en
insécurité
sorti en sécurité non par contre il
m'est arrivé de faire l'objet de menace
d'injures j'ai porté plainte directement
et je remercie les gendarmes pour leur
efficacité et la justice qui est passée
donc c'est très bien et si vous êtes en
heureux dernière question oui très
heureux et entouré avec plein de gens
formidables et notamment les habitants
de la commune merci Bertrand Houillon
d'avoir été avec nous je le rappelle
maire de la commune de Magny-les-Hameaux
est très bonne année 2023 dans votre
commune merci